welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and Breaking Bad
fans got a huge surprise this weekend
with the news that a film based on the
show named El Camino will be getting
released in October throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the movie as
well as what could happen in it
this video is potentially full of
spoilers so if you don't want to know
anything about the film then I highly
suggest that you turn off now there's a
lot to break down
so without the way let's get into
everything we know so far
about El Camino ok so firstly I thought
I'd go over the meaning of El Camino
fans of Breaking Bad are well aware that
titles in the show often have a double
meaning to them and examples of this can
be seen in the show's finale titled
Felina that episode title was a
reference to Felina a character from the
song el paso by Marty Robbins the song
tells the story of a man returning to a
town that exercised him to kill the
bandits that took his love and in the
end he dies after defeating the gang
this is of course pretty much the entire
plot the Breaking Bad finale and the
word Felina could also be broken up into
three different symbols of chemical
elements found in the periodic table
which are iron lithium and sodium this
is also add some fans to assume that the
final episode title means blood meth and
tears because iron is in blood lithium
is used in methamphetamine products and
sodium is a component of Tears so yeah
there's definitely potentially a lot to
unpack El Camino is not only a car but
it also means the way and the film will
likely pick up with Jesse escaping from
the season 5 compound and using it to go
on the road and hopefully find his way
the synopsis for the show reads
following the escape of a kidnapped man
and his quest for freedom which I think
adds a lot of weight to this El Camino
can also mean the king's highway as well
as the Royal Road so I think it's safe
to assume from this that the film will
be a road trip type film with Jesse on
the run from the authorities but who's
returning for the film well once more
the show will be heralded by Vince
Gilligan who created Breaking Bad and we
know that it is starring Aaron Paul as
Jesse Pinkman skinny pea is also making
a
however they've also been rumors that
Kristen Roth
Jesse's parents and even Bryan Cranston
are coming back
both he and Jane will probably be in
flashbacks as the characters along gone
though there's lots of speculation
around this when asked about an
appearance Cranston said the following
if Vince Gilligan asked me to do it sure
absolutely
he's a genius it's a great story and
there's a lot of people who felt that
they wanted to see some sort of
completion to some of these storylines
that were left open this idea from what
I was told
gets into at least a couple of the
characters who were not completed as far
as their journey I can't wait to see all
those people again even if I just come
by to visit so it looks like Cranston
has been at least told the ideas of the
script and included in on the plotline
in some form or another he may even
appear as a hallucination to Jessi
tormenting or even guiding the character
we know that Jessi is prone to delusion
due to the time he hallucinating that he
was a carpenter
so perhaps Walker will appear with him
on the road in some form or another
Jessi is probably damaged to do his
treatment and I can definitely see this
being a plot point that they travel down
in the trailer which was pretty
straightforward we see police
investigating pinkman's disappearance
and they clearly discovered the lab and
know about his work though his
involvement may still be unknown skinny
Pete mentions in the trailer that he
doesn't know where jesse is so they will
probably be spreading the investigation
far and wide and this could be a film
that sees the long arm of the law
reaching across America to try and track
down the character filming began on the
21st of November 2018 and the movie is
rumored to be roughly two hours in
length
lastly the film is due to be released
worldwide on October the 11th 2019 and
will be streamed exclusively on Netflix
we haven't had any official production
photos released just yet and it remains
to be seen whether the trailer itself
will feature in the film or just be part
of the promotions I think everyone is
very hype for the movie though I am
going in with tempered expectations I do
think that the finale of Breaking Bad is
the greatest final episode of a TV show
ever and it's always risky revisiting
things that wrapped up so well if it's
more of the same with Jessi just being
free then I don't know if it's the best
thing to do and it may leave
a bitter taste in fans mouths so
obviously anticipation is high I'm still
very very excited for the film now and I
can't wait to see what happens in it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you're excited for it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then make sure you
check out my breakdown of 13 reasons why
season 3 which would be linked at the
end I go over everything you need to
know about the Netflix show so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just want
to let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John wick 3 on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on El
Camino in the comment section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then whoever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]